I think it hurts probably a lot less
when it's just some random troll on
twitter or youtube or something that
says something rather than a friend to
rips your photo off a wall and you know
you thought you had some level of a
relationship but but that's that's great
that people have been encouraging i'm
wondering though for your own thoughts
about your career have you ever been
tempted to give up never never so you've
been in la your whole life yeah let me
call in college in San Diego and come
right back never been tempted to give up
everybody probably has a fleeting
thought into their head as much as any
weird fleeting thought but I've never
considered for more than a second if I
would stop doing this it's what I was
supposed to be doing I love to do it it
comes so natural to me bringing feel a
lot of happiness I've never thought
about stopping it no I thought about
shifting my focus was in entertainment
two different forms of comedy or
different types of shows but I've never
wanted to stop I don't think I'll ever
stop I'll be 105 years old doing Sam
comedy and probably doing a web series
of some kind well you have a smart cast
right at the last week on earth yeah and
you interviewed actor Bryan Cranston
yeah and he said to you it's really
important for anyone in the arts do not
put all your eggs in that one basket so
how do you take that advice is that
something sounds like you have so many
things going on when did you realize
that that advice is how you should
pretty much rule your career well I'd
already been doing that Cranston was
right here in the apartment and did the
podcast and I was incredible because
he's one of my favorite actors ever an
amazing human being and breaking bad my
hair show ever so I was just cool and
general to have him on my podcast but
when he said you don't apply your eggs
in one basket that was for me was very
apropos because I just started doing the
podcast and that was to me the constant
I could give myself to take the power
away from the casting directors and the
people that sometimes you know our it'll
be the gatekeepers of your success and
your happiness so it was nice to have
something that you know in addition to
my stand-up that's just like could jet
self generate and I could do and help
build my fan base with doing that but I
felt really bad lately in the fact that
I've not been able to do
kath last few months haven't been able
to find the time I bandwidth has just
been stretched too thin and with a lot
of other things a little bit of life I
have to find time in there as well I
can't always be just creating stuff for
other people and I feel really bad that
I've you know I did the podcast almost
every week for three years and I've not
been doing it so much lately but I will
be doing it again I will be to bring it
back but you know Cranston's advice I've
always understood that I've always
spread myself pretty thin is actually a
problem for me it's I think I'd be doing
better my career if I were focused on a
fewer things but I just like it all I
want to do it all and so I just made
peace recently with the fact that's just
in me and it's Who I am and so my career
will go and more of this trajectory
instead of this trajectory but it's
still forward progress because the shape
ends up going like this kind of like a
whale's tail but forward if the way of
the tables in the front of a whale and
then he could swim forward by wet yes
sure sure i'm mentioning the wife the
way tables in front and then it went
like this and then the front part you
could go like that yeah and it would
propel him forward even though you
wouldn't think it would it's the point
you